pessoal não quero criar discórdia só
acho que a informação precisa ser
passada de forma correta a hora pronobis
é maravilhosa é barata e acessível o seu
consumo deve ser incentivado mas vocês
precisam saber que tem umas informações
aí desencontradas divergentes por aí
sobre as proteínas e suas quantidades
para cumprir o seu bom papel como fonte
Alternativa de proteínas a h pronomes é
muito mais vantajosa quando consumida
seca comparada com outros vegetais
famosos como é o caso do grão de bico
que tem cerca de 9 G de proteína por 100
g de alimento e o feijão que tem 5 g de
proteína por 100 g de alimento as folhas
de H pronobis TM só 3 G de proteína em
100 g mas adivinhe só esse número
dispara quando a planta é analisada seca
chegando a impressionantes 15 g de
proteína em 100 g o desafio reside no
fato de que a farinha seca das Folhas da
H pronobis não é o método mais comum de
consumo o que pode sugerir uma falta de
conhecimento geral das pessoas sobre
Esse aspecto crucial